well you
worked we talked about this in the last
podcast but you were a casting director
you were like right you were a caster
and a casting director assistant or what
was it no i worked in background you
worked in background so you would hire
background people so like the casting
agent
the background casting agent would call
me and be like i need this many people
that look kind of like this to work in
this kind of scene
and then i would go through my roster
and find who i could
and then i would put them on a set
mostly usually small though
really
yeah because we were modeling agency and
they only wanted pretty people in there
geez smallville yeah they had what's her
name on there they had what's her name
from lost remember what's her name
eventually did you did you hire her as a
extra you did
you were the one who said evangeline
lily what is her name evangeline lilly
is
she's pretty she needs to be on the show
so she was an extra she was background
while we were filming smallville
yeah
damn do you want to know something crazy
please this is another crazy thing about
the business
i was in la
for pilot season when when lost came out
and up here they wanted to see me for
lost but i wasn't here and so
they convinced angeline lilly to go in
for the audition
really you could have been unlocked
but you got lois lane
right so i was fine but my point is
i had to get over that
there was a moment where i was just like
son of
but
well you i think you learn as you get
older as you get older but but again
that's
putting all of the scenarios as if you
could walk in and be that look like it
was all meant to be her thing
but as an actor you can get your head
totally twisted around with the idea and
sell yourself on the sentimentality that
but had i gone in for that audition i i
would have had the chance
yeah
yeah i i honestly i don't know if you've
ever had that or like been driving
around all day and see a billboard and
you're like
why did i talk about this maybe i didn't
maybe i did i'm sure in 204 episodes
i've talked about it
or michael something like that but what
i do
is i do the audition and they give you
what's called side so you have the sides
that you read it's the pages that you
read and the second i'm done i turn out
i walk out of the casting director's
door
and i rip up the sides and i throw them
away and i walk out
you do that too absolutely yeah i do the
scenes on set it's like it's [ __ ]
done it's done get it out of your head
next next what's next what's next
you